beginning in fort erie ontario a number
of trucks slow rolled their way to the
niagara region sunday morning this is
not just for the truckers
this is the backbone they are they are
the backbone of canada
and the canadian and american good
freedom freedom protests like these come
as convoys across the country are
heading to ottawa to oppose a vaccine
mandate which requires truckers
traveling back and forth across the u.s
border to be immunized against coba 19.
sylvan charlebois says the mandate is
coming at the wrong time he fears it
will drive up the price of consumer
goods i think we're at a point now
in in the pandemic that we need to
strike a more functional balance between
saving lives and keeping canadians fed
the latest pushback on vaccine mandates
from truck drivers draws a parallel with
canada's ongoing divide over public
health restrictions it prompts the
question as to whether policy is
matching the science rather than chasing
down the unvaccinated we should be
pushing our governments
to deal with the global health risk
that's in front of all of us bioethicist
carrie bowman believes the government
should focus on vaccinating the rest of
the world instead of the holdouts in
canada others such as dr isaac bogot say
policymakers shouldn't keep measures in
place longer than necessary whenever a
policy is being implemented i think we
have to ask ourselves what's the goal
here like what are you actually trying
to do both agree there should be
flexibility in how pandemic policy is
shaped in the future that's probably one
of the most important aspects
to question when you're making policy
and sadly i think sometimes that gets
lost brittany rosen global news toronto